well i'm not asking for a raise i'm
gonna actually be asking for a paid
decrease
uh that is so stupid
what if he gives it to you
i win ugh you know what i am going to
zone you out for the rest of today okay
i need to stay focused
and i don't have to see you tomorrow or
sunday and please don't call me and
we'll see how things go on monday
stupid
wait one thing
um but tomorrow you mean saturday right
today is thursday but dwight thinks that
it's friday
and
that's what i'll be working on this
afternoon
michael and jan definitely made out oh
maybe more
oh also it is thursday but dwight thinks
it's friday so we'll keep that going
damn this is jim it is about 11 15 and i
wanted to know what you were up to
tomorrow which is the 15th and that is a
saturday saturday so just let me know
what you're doing tomorrow saturday for
lunch okay talk to you soon
hey jim hey how's it going oh my god did
you see the apprentice last night of
course it's on every thursday night so
how could i miss it can you believe who
trump fired no that was unbelievable who
who was it who did he fire you didn't
see it no
i went out and got drunk with my laser
tag team last night crap
never go out on a thursday night what
the hell was i thinking
hey
it's 12 20 where the hell's dwight
um
no idea never miss a day my ass
over here
i'm here
over here it's okay
a little help
wow your hair is really thinning
standing has proven to be healthier
increases productivity and just looks
cooler picture someone doing something
heroic now was he sitting or standing
not counting fdr
every second you sit there is an hour
off your life
look at all of you i feel like you're in
a suicide cult no no no you're way off
on that one are you really comfortable
standing there i tried one of those and
i just couldn't find the sweet spot
hey guys let's just all admit it okay
dwight's better than us
he had the guts to stop sitting and he's
never
ever gonna go back on it right that's
right jim
hey man hey
taking the load off huh no putting a
load on more like good luck with that
last thing i need is luck
thank you so much
[Music]
give that back come on prank
oh that's real creative you know what
you're right it's not my best cause you
could easily just bend over and pick
that up right i could i just don't feel
like a loser because you're sitting
standing okay
don't because you're sitting standing
you know i have to do this
i know
you should get one of these
no thank you
do you even know what this is
it is a fitness orb and it has
completely changed my life
forget everything you thought you knew
about ab workouts
done
this ab workout is specifically designed
to strengthen your core
sorry all right
numerous health benefits
strengthens your back
better performance in sports
more enjoyable sex
you're not having sex
plus
improve your reflexes
i would have caught that okay you know
what uh how much is that
uh it's only 25 bucks wow
um
okay
i just had a couple of notes let me grab
a pen and
damn it
ah just when we were
just when we were getting going
seriously
you're gonna send me back
uh yeah it's the safest part of a car in
the event of a crash driver always
protects his side first
i know a lot of us have been feeling
under the weather lately it's that time
of year and according to a study done by
the university of arizona they
discovered that your keyboards have
hundreds of times more bacteria per
square inch than a toilet seat i heard
your mama has more bacteria per square
inch than a toilet seat that's true
that's true i dated her mama and you
know what sorry i'm done
all right one of the simplest ways to
cut down on the spread of germs is to
use something called the vampire cough
did do you say vampire oh no it's just
that if a vampire had to cough he would
do it like this
uh-huh right and ruin their cloaks do
you have any idea how expensive wool is
in transylvania because of the euro well
other things you can do to help cut down
on the spread of disease are to wash
your hands regularly
don't come in if you're sick
and get your flu shot also i'm going to
set up hand sanitizing stations around
the office no no no they will cost you
your life elaborate the worst thing you
can do for your immune system is to
coddle it they need to fight their own
battles if saber really cared about our
well-being they would set up hand
desanitizing stations a simple bowl at
every juncture filled with dirt vomit
fecal matter exposing yourself to germs
is the best way to make yourself
stronger so by that rationale if i had
to sneeze i should just sneeze on you
yes i would welcome it
you're welcome
the principle is sound to avoid illness
expose yourself to germs enabling your
immune system to develop antibodies
i don't know why everyone doesn't do
this
maybe they have something against living
forever
thank you sir no thank you i never let
anyone walk behind me seven out of ten
attacks are from the rear okay well that
still leaves a 30 chance that i'll
attack you from the front uh yeah but
it'll be easier to stop i can always
block the blow or i can counter it with
it
i didn't really get a good look
that's okay
i don't feel like answering phones hey
did you guys see this memo that dwight
sent out
women will be sent home if they wear
makeup or heels exceeding one-quarter
inch females are not allowed to speak to
strangers unless given written
authorization by dwight schrute this is
ridiculous attention i am removing all
bananas from the kitchen
dwight
this memo that you distributed is
insulting desperate times call for
desperate measures sleeves down to the
wrists button up collars and muted
colors nobody dresses like that
that is pretty cool
think we'll find him yeah i do
cause justice never rests
tabzis
no
holsies
listen man i really appreciate you
letting me shadow you today i feel like
i learned a lot match
yep
if you don't mind i think i'll hang up
some of these posters around my
neighborhood schools
post office etc
you know
i may have underestimated you
you're not a total ass
thunder milf and paper slash sex
predator hotline this is dwight schrute
hey dwight it's jim
jim what are you doing i'm busy
no you're not i'm looking right at you
ugh don't
i have information about the sex
predator
you have information about the sex
predator
i saw him two minutes ago
where
in the women's bathroom above the sink
anti-flashing task force
above the sink
above the sink hmm
you